(upbeat sitar music)
- [Narrator] In Northern Bangladesh,
just below the Himalayas, there's a school
unlike any you've probably seen.
Rather than brick-and-mortar buildings,
these classrooms float.
(kids chattering)
(contemplative percussion
and chimes music)
In most of Bangladesh, the roads are poor,
and the environment is powerful.
Every year, over a fifth
of the country floods,
isolating people in small villages
and cutting kids off from school.
So a man named Mohammed
Rezwan had an idea.
(engine rumbling)
(water splashes)
- [Narrator] There are different boats
with different purposes.
There are classroom boats, library boats,
boats for computers,
and even ones for play.
In groups of 30, kids aged
six to 10 attend classes
covering the main points of
early childhood education.
- [Narrator] With millions
of children out of school
in Bangladesh, these kids are getting
a chance that many others don't-
a chance to learn and
hopefully change their lives.
(reflective wooden chimes music)
(contemplative synth music)